tous
[Musique]
montréal cet homme a été membre de
l'opus dei pendant 30 ans et cette
maison lui rappelle de mauvais souvenirs
il a d'abord communiquer avec nous sous
une fausse identité
sur papier l'opposé ce très beau bien
sûr dans la pratique c'est horrible
il serait le premier canadien à dévoiler
ce qu'il a vécu au sein de cette
organisation
[Applaudissements]
et depuis ce temps là je fais très
attention
oui oui c'est j'ai encore propose
absolument
il a quitté il ya dix ans et malgré tout
il a peur de parler
[Musique]
j'ai mis des années des années
traverser la rue fois d'acheter une
baguette de pain c'était terrible je
pouvais pas j'ai toujours la passion qui
me suivait
en france cette femme est à l'origine
d'un procès historique contre une école
lié à l'opus dei
manipulation mentale n'y a pas de
preuves ya rien c'est là où c'est
dangereux
[Musique]
au mexique cet ancien directeur de
l'opus dei a fait des découvertes qu'ils
ont ébranlé
le pays n'est pas une mauvaise chose
mais il ya un côté sombre les secrets
les mensonges
l'aïe c'est une organisation qui pressés
membres comme des citrons les gens
doivent en être informés pis pour nous
le plus d y aurait contrôlé leur vie et
dominer leurs esprits
ces anciens membres le sentiment d'avoir
été soumis à une autorité abusive brimés
dans leur liberté et compterait and
supply noster et se sont senti piégé on
est des laïcs au milieu du monde mais en
fait un centre de refuser dans une rue c
c'est comme une prison sans peur
[Musique]
nous avons eu plusieurs échanges avec
lui avant de gagner un peu sa confiance
ce n'est qu'au moment de l'entrevue
qu'il nous dévoile son véritable nom
vincent du rocher
ces craintes viennent de ce qu'il a vécu
dit et c'est un chemin de persécution un
chemin d'or seulement un chemin de coups
bas c'était malheureux mais ça a été ça
son histoire commence à 19 ans il étudie
à l'université de montréal lorsqu'un ami
il invite à une rencontre
donc j'ai assisté pour la première fois
et j'ai rencontré des gens il y avait
beaucoup de gens ces jeunes y avait des
universités y avait des professionnels
il y avait je pense un ou deux prêtres
qui étaient là aussi qui habite la
résidence
vincent est un jeune catholique
pratiquant ce qu'il entend ce soir là
répond à son idéal le plus dit il lui
propose d'en faire plus pour vivre sa
foi mais il n'a aucune idée de ce qui
l'attend dans l'opus dei on va pas
expliquer beaucoup là on va pas dit tu
vas donner tout ton argent comptant et
tout ça on n'a pas dit ça on m'a dit
qu'il va donner ta vie dans le plus payé
c'est après fur et à mesure qu'on vous
explique
et que l'aca de sas précisé
vincent du rocher fait le saut et
devient numéraire c'est à dire un membre
célibataire qui fait les mêmes promesses
qu'un prêtre chasteté pauvreté et
obéissance
au cours des premiers mois on lui
explique l'esprit de l'opus dei et on
lui présente le plan de vie il y a dans
le plan qu'on demande au monde numéraire
le châtelet à tous les jours j'appelle
ça une vingtaine de minutes une visite
au saint sacrement à tous les jours
[Musique]
la liste des dévotions que les membres
sont encouragés à pratiquer est longue
nous avons obtenu une copie du plan de
vie que vincent durocher a connu
baiser le seul en se levant prendre une
douche froide priez 30 minutes le matin
assister à la messe faire un examen de
conscience deux fois par jour se
confesser se flageller réciter à genoux
les bras en croix 3 je vous salue marie
avant de se coucher
on en rajoute tout le temps c'est
toujours on vous dit bah oui fais ci
fais ça plus ce sont vous demande
d'essayer de rencontrer des amis faire
l'apostolat dans votre milieu
donc
oui c'est assez exigeant bien sûr et
l'opus dei veut dire l'oeuvre de dieu le
groupe a été fondé par josémaria escriva
de balaguer en 1928 en espagne l'oeuvre
est une institution catholique qui a
séduit le vatican par son côté novateur
permettra des laïcs d'atteindre la
sainteté dans le travail et la vie de
tous les jours le fondateur a été
déclarée 5 par le pape jean paul ii
[Musique]
nos recherches ne laisse penser que
l'opus dei semble éviter les projecteurs
puisque très peu de choses ont été dites
sur cette organisation au pays ce que
nous en savons nous vient
essentiellement du film le code davinci
sorti en 2006 un moine albinos assoiffés
de pouvoir se flagellent et multiplie
les assassinats de la pure fiction
[Musique]
les membres de l'opus dei ne sont pas
des catholiques ordinaire ils pratiquent
leur religion avec ardeur lee numéraire
sont incités à se flageller une fois par
semaine et a porté le cilice deux heures
par jour pour partager les souffrances
du christ c'est une espèce de couronne
en métal avec des pointes consommer
autour des jambes qu'on doit porter deux
heures par jour c'est serré l'esprit de
pénitence est très fort dans l'opus dei
ça fait mal
le jour vincent du rocher enseigne la
biologie dans une école secondaire
le soir il rentre chez lui dans une
résidence de l'opus dei où il vit avec
d'autres membres numéraire
son salaire est versé au complet à
l'organisation
on lui remet de l'argent de poche 40 $
par semaine mais des fois on me donnait
20 ont donné dix c'est arrivé souvent
que j'ai manqué d'argent que j'ai dû
emprunter à des collègues
le plus d y contrôler son compte en
banque ces allées et venues lit son
courrier et selon vincent du rocher il
surveille aussi ses activités sur
internet aller au cinéma ou au théâtre
est interdite certains livres et
articles de journaux une sont tous y
parle beaucoup de liberté dans le musée
mais honnêtement j'ai jamais vu une
organisation qui respecte - la liberté
personnelle que l'épousé est à présent
non pas en prison je peux aller prendre
un café avec un ami je peux aller voir
ma famille mais on vous dit tout le
temps vous devez dire un des directeurs
ou vous allez donc elles savent à tout
moment où vous êtes si une autre façon
de contrôler les gens si
[Musique]
comme enseignant vincent du rocher à des
cours à préparer et des corrections à
faire en soirée comme membre numéraire
on lui demande d'assister à des cercles
de discussion dû suivre des formations
spirituel il doit être disponible en
tout temps pour répondre aux demandes de
l'organisation il n'a plus aucun temps
libre dit il faut que je me batte avec
le directeur pour regarder la télé 15
minutes nommé des choses puisque pour
moi c'était normal je suis fatigué je
vais me reposer pour eux c'était un
scandale alors commence à tout le monde
vincent regarde la télé war
c'est pour vous dire c'est s'est écrasé
contrôle et vincent du rocher accumule
les frustrations il affirme qu'on se
moque de lui et de ses demandes il
devient dépressif on ne sait pas me
reposer on ne m'écoutait pas j'étais
épuisé
donc c'est ça plus si vous mettez ça le
côté physique le côté stress le côté
harcèlement ça fait beaucoup dans
l'assiette là ça fait beaucoup ça
partout dans le monde le puce administre
des écoles de restauration et
d'hôtellerie leur but former de bons
employés et répandre le message de
l'oeuvre la sanctification à travers le
travail ordinaire le couvre-lit reste
bien droit
le plus d y compte aussi parmi ses rangs
des numéraires auxiliaires des femmes
qui se dévoue aux tâches domestiques
dans les maisons de l'opus leur réalité
a été captée par une équipe de
télévision française dé quoi tant besoin
pour sauver son âme croire en dieu
évidemment vivre ses commandements et
vivre de la grâce de dieu rien de plus
et tu veux être un sens oui je vais être
une sainte et je pense que c'est pour
cela que dieu m'a appelé j'ai dit ce que
j'avais à l'époque vraiment j'ai
exactement on est formaté en fait tout
le monde ait la même chose
[Musique]
catherine tissier a tourné la page sur
son passé de numéraires auxiliaires
elle vit aujourd'hui à sens en france
c'est là que nous l'avons rencontré
à 14 ans elle fréquente l'école dosnon à
deux heures de paris c'est ici qu'elle
entre en contact avec l'opus dei un
institut d'hôtellerie gérés par des
membres de l'oeuvre mais à ce moment-là
qu'est ce que vous connaissiez de l'opus
dei rien du tout je ne savais même pas
que c'était l'opus dei c'était pas
marqué sur les plaquettes de l'école
elle se lie d'amitié avec une
enseignante catherine ignore alors
qu'elle est membre de l'opus dei cette
femme va progressivement l'initié au
monde de l'oeuvre à la fin de ma
deuxième année nous a passé un film du
fondateur de l'opus dei et c'est eux qui
petit à petit après ce film n'est bon
ben voila si tu veux
toujours avec beaucoup de temps et
beaucoup de douceur
si tu veux pas tous les mercredis à un
aumônier qui vient école qui fait des
méditations tu peux venir voir ce russe
et ça se passe dans la chapelle de
l'école ont dit oui pour faire plaisir
en fait moi ça a été ça au début du mois
on me demande ça se fait trop faut
qu'elle me le 10 juillet les pieds après
j'aurai la peine en fait on rentre petit
à petit en quand on y va pour la
première fois on rentre dans l'engrenage
c'est bien qu'à la fin de ses études
elle s'engage comme numéraire haut
d'hier elle n'a que 16 ans quand j'ai
fini l'école on a des réparant bon bah
voilà votre chez elle fait partie de
creuser maintenant sa famille chez nous
c'est plus vos à partir de ce moment là
elle n'a plus aucun loisirs les sorties
sont contrôlés elle n'a pas d'amis et se
sent surveillé
et on est toujours à 2 pourquoi parce
que au cas où une personne n'a envie de
dévier un petit peu de regarder à
quelque chose bail est toujours l'autre
qui est là pour lui dire attention on se
surveille mutuellement catherine tissier
va travailler pendant dix ans dans
différents centres lié à l'opus elle se
lève tôt et se couche tard à vivre du
temps pour vous non en fait on n'a pas
le temps pour se retrouver seul et pour
pouvoir penser à porte à porte
après quelques années catherine est
épuisée et devient dépressive elle ne se
sent plus elle même mois un moment je
pouvais commencer une phrase la personne
qui on connait c'est fini c'est la
phrase pour moi c'est pas si c'était moi
qui l'avais dit fait elle nous connaît
de l'intérieur c'est très très insidieux
et dix dernières années plus ça allait
plus je me disais ça pas de sens c'est
trop il faut que je m'en aille mais
entre le fait de dire il faut que je
m'en aille et puis le fait de partir
c'est pas facile vous habiter chez eux
ou est-ce que vous allez aller dans la
rue puisque vous allez habiter
vous n'avez pas accès à votre compte en
banque comment vous allez faire si vous
partez
[Musique]
la résidence review au pied du mont
royal à montréal c'est ici que vincent
durocher a été invitée pour la première
fois à une rencontre de l'oeuvre le plus
d y ait accepté de nous ouvrir ses
portes mario jardon nous accueille
il est 6 heures du matin la journée des
numéraires commence par la prière
[Musique]
de nombreux numéraire et un prêtre vite
ici
review est une résidence universitaire
les sept étudiants connaissent
l'orientation catholique de la maison
mais ne sont pas soumis aux mêmes
devoirs religieux
après le déjeuner se numéraire quitte
pour le travail
[Musique]
mario jardon reste il est le directeur
de vivre view comment cette découverte
comme le travail peut être en même temps
quelque chose qui nous perfection
quelque chose qui nous aide à développer
nos talents et service aux autres est en
fait aussi une forme de prière tu es
heureux dans le bus des hits la zone
ça fait trente ans que je suis à fixer
dans la chapelle trône le portrait du
fondateur saint josémaria escriva
[Musique]
galfond
d'alcoologie en accueille tarbes
on le regarde avec certainement
affection gratitude et reconnaissance
pour pour sauver sa
générosité
le fondateur promet la sainteté à ceux
qui suivent ses enseignements
tout est condensé dans un petit livre de
poche contenant 999 maxime camino le
chemin
le plus dit avoir 90 mille membres dans
le monde au canada il serait 900 dont
124 numéraire comme vincent du rocher 23
auxiliaires comme catherine tissier
des chiffres impossibles à vérifier
puisque la liste des membres est
confidentiel
mais la majorité des membres sont des
gens mariés qui ont des enfants on les
appelle les surnuméraires il participe
aux activités du groupe et à son
financement deux pour cent des membres
sont des prêtres ils ont tous la même
mission sanctifier le monde par le
travail ce n'est pas un hasard c'est un
fait bien connu l'opus dit recrutent
beaucoup
dans ce qu'on appelle les élites c'est à
dire les gens instruits le sociologue
des religions martin geoffroy considère
que le ppu ce manque de transparence
c'est qu'on va recruter des gens dans
des postes de pouvoir dans la société
ces gens là qui ont les postes de
pouvoir la société si son discrédit
spock se rendre au pays peuvent exercer
une influence
au canada le plus d y est liée à une
trentaine d'associations culturelles et
sportives
des clubs de jeunes des camps de
vacances
le plus d'y exercer une mission
pastorale
il le fait également dans une école
secondaire privée à toronto
mais c'est du recrutement c'est du
recrutement à long terme à long terme
c'est un investissement à long terme
c'est tout sinon pourquoi faire tant
l'activité avec les jeunes
il y a neuf résidences étudiantes comme
un levier au pays la plupart situés près
des universités
mario jardon n'a pas toujours dirigé la
résidence où ils habitent en tant que
docteur en génie chimique il a longtemps
travaillé dans des entreprises privées
il fait aujourd'hui du mentorat auprès
des résidants et leur parle du monde du
travail et de la vie spirituelle
un point que le fondateur de le poser
une au numéro 7 la dernière partie ne
vole pas comme les oiseaux de basse-cour
quand tu peux élever comme un aigle il
avait ses maurice est entré dans
l'oeuvre à l'âge de 15 ans à titre
d'agent des communications de l'opus dei
au pays elle a défendu l'image de
l'organisation au moment de la sortie du
film le code davinci en 2006 lui il
utilise le silence et la discipline pour
explique pour le maire ce nouveau revers
dans le poser en vie pour des meurtres
on vit pour emi pourrait me les hommes
et pour aimer dieu
elle occupe les mêmes fonctions
aujourd'hui moi je me suis super bien
comme numéraire je travaille pas je me
couche fatigué mais content elle est
accompagnée de genre ni philibert
membres surnuméraires depuis un an est
ce que le but d'accueillir des étudiants
universitaires dans ses résidences c'est
quand même de tenter d'en recruter
quelques uns moi si je m'intéresse à
dieu vous bien que je peux sans parler
du manque les résidences servat soit
puisse accueille déjà 2 de tous les
horizons c'est bien évidemment les
milieux universitaires sont des endroits
de débats des endroits heures de
discussions c'est pas que c'est sur la
performance de deux roues cdc spa
macdonald macy personne devient maman
bout de ligne il va avoir un problème
d'accord avec vous la survie de le pouce
dit elle ne dépend pas du nombre de
membres quoi que ce soit des pins de
dieu évidemment ça fait partie de nos
prières et nos prix pour accueillir des
gens qui s'intéressent à la vie qui y
entrent à l'oeuvre si je vous disais le
nombre de personnes que j'ai trouvé que
j'ai amené à l'opposé
combien de gens racontent combien pour
une dizaine en saint-quentin pas une
dizaine et on m'a jamais reproché son
isabelle c'est maurice affirme qu'il
n'ya aucune obligation de recrutement
pourtant d'autres membres nous ont dit
le contraire
disait tout le temps il faut trouver des
membres numéraire moi ça me tapait sur
les nerfs l'objectif normalement c'est
de ramener six à sept personnes dans
l'opus dei par cet événement est une
arme en a oui et aussi moi je me disais
bon c'est bien le monde ni même les plus
importants c'est pas ça c'est d'aider
les gens se rapprocher du cube mais
c'était toujours non numéraire non
numéraires membres s'étaient rabâcher
l'idée c'était de conserver voilà parce
que aussi s'il ya pas de numéraire on
peut pas ouvrir de nouvelles résidences
le gouvernement central de l'opus dei se
trouve à rome un conseil régional gère
les activités au canada puis chaque
résidence à son conseil local composé de
trois directeurs parmi eux il ya un
directeur spirituel qui est la
responsabilité de guider les membres
dans leur foi dès le début on me dit il
faut que tu parles de tous c'est à dire
tout absolument tout au tout quand je
dis tous et où les droits des gardés
aucun secret pour vous même un absolu
mourir
pour lui lee directeur de conscience
s'apparentait des big boi d'heure ils
veulent savoir tous les aspects
personnels qu'est ce que tu as fait avec
tel ami qu'est ce que tu fais avec ta
famille je veux dire on rentre dans son
aspect très très très très personnel
lee directeur spirituel contre olemps et
indiscrets on ne respecte pas l'intimité
de la conscience des gens c'est à dire
si quelqu'un vous confie quelque chose
dans son intimité on commence pas en
parler à toulouse et eux ils le font
mais mois selon je passais des
directeurs de conscience qu'ils vont
partager l'information ou ce que la
personne va lui avoir dit à d'autres
directeurs de la même maison
des directeurs de conscience lors on
peut se poser c'est pas juste choisi
sans quoi se poser non sont pas supposés
non sens qu'est ce que c'est que ça se
fasse
c'est lui qui a eu des erreurs ça se
peut qu'ils aient dérapé des erreurs qui
sont assez importants l'idée d'avoir une
personne qui nous est attitré pour
pouvoir se confier sur le plan spirituel
sévérin dans l'optique de s'entraider de
créer des liens de confiance avoue
d'amasser des de confiance sont brisés
c'est grave pour le pays lee directeur
spirituel ne sont que des
accompagnateurs les membres sont libres
de leur confier ce qu'ils veulent oui
mais vincent du rocher est persuadé que
le plus d y a même compilé des
informations personnelles à son sujet
les membres de l'opus seraient fichés
c'est une des choses vraiment qui m'a
beaucoup beaucoup
révoltés dans notre estime tous les
membres de l'opposition fichés c'est
comme la cia
je faisais comme les autres directeurs
je m'immisce est dans leur esprit leur
âme leurs réflexions leurs sentiments
dans tout je savais tout
carlos miguel a été directeur spirituel
dans plusieurs centres de l'opus dei né
en espagne il est entré dans
l'organisation à l'adolescence il ya
passé 34 ans de sa vie il vit au mexique
depuis qu'il a quitté l'opus
carlos miguel connaît des secrets de
l'opus dei d'abord il nous montre un
document interne
c'est un petit bout de papier il
contient toutes les normes
c'est comme ça qu'on les appelle 10 ce
sont les choses qu'on doit faire tous
les jours de notre vie
des normes l'équivalent du plan de vie
dont nous a parlé vincent du rocher
cette fiche sert à l'auto-évaluation
léman peuvent s'y inscrire les dévotions
accompli mais elle aurait surtout pour
but de mettre en lumière les faiblesses
carlos miguel a rempli ses fiches tous
les jours pendant 34 ans il affirme que
dans les centres de l'opus dei les
directeurs s'échanger entre eux les
confidences des membres
imaginez
les directeurs discutent entre eux des
problèmes des autres membres et ensuite
ils écrivent ça sur une feuille qui est
envoyé au bureau de l'opus dei de cette
ville
[Musique]
puis
on ne se contente pas de parler de ce
que vivent les membres on l'écrit
en tant que directeur carlos miguel a
lui même rédigé des rapports secrets
évidemment tout se fait à l'aide de
codes ses quad core de codes secrets b10
tirait sans
38-5
cecon indique un problème de chasteté
peut-être dans sa tête une affaire de
masturbation de pornographie peu importe
ses rapports détaillés seraient cruciaux
à l'organisation
par exemple intel n'est pas aussi humble
qu'on le croyait
fini
il doit apprendre à faire davantage
confiance à dieu il ne fait pas une
bonne utilisation de son argent
alors isabelle c'est maurice et
jean-rené philibert n'ont jamais vu ce
type de rapport et ans nie l'existence
il ajoute que ce n'est pas dans l'esprit
de l'opus dei que rédiger des documents
semblables
tous les documents écrits par les
directeurs à propos des gens doivent
être gardés secrets les membres
concernés ne le savent surtout pas
après quatre ans comme numéraire
auxiliaire catherine tissier s'est mis à
douter de sa vocation est en fait je
devenais un robot
je faisais ce qu'il y avait à faire j'ai
essayé de tenir debout comme je pouvais
on dit tout et je n'avais pas de logique
jamais j'avais plus rien du tout parce
qu'à un moment ou deux je me suis un
petit peu rebellé contre contre l'opus
des j'ai commencé à vouloir dire que je
voulais partir mais monsieur
physiquement je n'avais pas moyen
une directrice la compagne alors j'ai un
médecin membre de l'opus dei donc lui a
commencé à me soit disant soigner en
mettant son ancien les tickets
antidépresseurs et en augmentant les
doses au fur et à mesure du peu de
logique que j'avais je l'avais plus
jeter un zombie
[Musique]
la santé de catherine tissier s'aggrave
sans que sa famille soit mise au courant
en 2001 lors de son congé annuel
séparant la trouve dans un état
lamentable
elle ne pèse que 85 if he a du mal à se
tenir sur ses jambes
ses parents l'amène chez leur médecin de
famille est là avec l l'ordonance
d'antidépresseurs fournies par le
médecin de l'opus dei et quand tu es
montrer leur donnant je reverrai
toujours sa tête et l'a dit mais c'est
pas possible
c'est pas possible d'avoir autant de
médicaments
et du coup il m'a dit tu n'y a pas de
choix soit tu restes ici à moi et tu te
reposes soit demain dit plus sur terre
au dernier endroit où j'ai vécu sur les
quinze personnes qui vivaient là 12 où
l'on avait des problèmes de santé
mentale c'est grave
sa vie entière du lever au coucher
à se faire imposer ce niveau de
perfection ce n'est pas ça
qui n'a pas le temps de se reposer parce
qu'on n'est pas censé se reposer on est
censé se faire presser comme un citron
[Musique]
évidemment les épuisements et les
troubles de santé mentale comme la
dépression sont extrêmement commun parce
qu'on n'a jamais le sentiment
d'atteindre ce niveau de sainteté de
perfection
selon les informations de nombreux
numéraire et numéraires auxiliaires sont
sous antidépresseurs
mais comment fait savoir ceci moi parce
que si les gens me disent peau moi j'ai
pas de sources mais j'ai pas de raison
de savoir saut alors à ce moment là la
personne peut voir son médecin aussi
pour savoir un puce qui se passe avec
elle vincent du rocher et d'autres
anciens membres affirment avoir été
fortement incitée à consulter un médecin
membre de l'opus dei alors on m'a un
membre doit consulter un médecin qui est
membre de l'organisation s'il y en a
d'autres dates est ce
parce que c'est le seul moyen pour les
directeurs de savoir ce qui se passe
avec cette personne
c'est incroyable on vit dans une société
libre on devrait aller voir le médecin
qu'on veut pas le médecin de l'opus dei
soit par exemple c'est une preuve de
contrôle c'est un contrôle exacerbée qui
devrait pas exister moi quand j'étais
directrice d'un centre les gens
n'avaient pas l'obligation j'ai jamais
passer ce message là pour moi jamais d'y
aller un autre médecin un médecin de le
poser
en france 4 un petit s'ils veulent
obtenir justice
cette femme catherine tissier dit avoir
travaillé pendant 13 ans 12 heures par
jour pour une misère à l'école technique
privée d'hôtellerie dosnon dans l'aisne
et dans d'autres établissements gérés
par l'opus dei le procès s'ouvre
l'association qui gère l'école de nom et
deux membres de l'opus dei sont
poursuivis pour travail dissimulé et
rétribution contraire à la dignité
catherine tissier veut être dédommagée
pour séquelles psychologiques qu'elle
attribue à l'opus dei elle demande aussi
d'être pays pour les heures travaillées
mais au fil des procédures qui vont
durer quinze ans la cour écarte le plus
d i le combat de catherine sera limité à
la portion relatives à sa rémunération
le juge conclut que la direction de
l'école dosnon lié à l'opus dei a
profité de la vulnérabilité de l'ancien
numéraire auxiliaire
[Musique]
catherine tissier reçoit 26800 euros
soit près de 40000 dollars canadiens en
indemnités une victoire partielle mais
qui fait toute la différence pour elle
[Musique]
d'avoir été reconnues victimes
ça y est pour beaucoup procès n'aurait
pas abouti y aurait toujours eu
inconsciemment un doute mais là non ça a
été écrit noir sur blanc elles ont été
condamnées dont
[Musique]
nous avons joint l'opus dei en france
qui rappelle qu'il n'a pas été poursuivi
directement
le plus d ea se dissocie totalement de
l'école de deux noms pourtant le procès
met en lumière des liens entre l'oeuvre
et la direction de l'école
catherine tissier n'est pas seul à
contester publiquement l'opus dei en
argentine 42 ancien numéraires
auxiliaires ont écrit au pape françois
cet été elles demandent son intervention
pour que les abus soit reconnu et que
l'opus leur paie des retraites
le tap françois leur a répondu de porter
plainte officiellement au vatican ce
qu'elles viennent de faire
oui oui maintenant tu la façon dont
l'opus traite les femmes
particulièrement les numéraires
auxiliaires est inimaginable
carlos miguel prépare un balado sur
l'opus dei il a interviewé douze
anciennes numéraire auxiliaire qui ont
quitté il ya une dizaine d'années
lors ici le bouleverse
c'est très difficile s
j'apprends beaucoup de choses en faisant
ses ballades aux
choses que j'ignorais complètement
pour être bien honnête je suis un peu
traumatisés
ces femmes sont des esclaves dutil dit
numéraire auxiliaire de différents pays
lui ont raconté qu'elles devaient
travailler sans arrêt et dormir sur des
planches de bois il comprend maintenant
que celle qu'il a connue ont pu être
soumise aux mêmes conditions
c'est absolument rien des personnes qui
nous servent qui lave nos vêtements il
faut qu'ils nous préparent à manger
ils font nous lie qui nettoie nos salles
de bains qui garde notre environnement
dans un état impeccable
évidemment que je n'étais pas au courant
c'est la raison pour laquelle je suis
ici ébranlé
s'est
aggravée
est-ce que des situations ce que des
fois il ya des profiteurs ça sera
dénoncé chez nous à coteau du lac près
de valleyfield c'est ce numéraire
auxiliaire s'occupe de l'entretien du
manoir de beau jeu où l'opus tient des
retraites et des conférences ces femmes
habitent juste à côté à l'école
d'hôtellerie soulanges
selon isabelle c'est maurice lee
numéraire auxiliaire canadienne sont
bien traités moi je les vois sont tous
dans les mêmes conditions de ce côté là
le haut niveau ça là le niveau des
bénéfices itou et puis elle les voit
vivre
non on n'a pas ces conditions là du tout
faisait ces personnes qui vont avoir du
temps pour sortir dans un van du temps
pour sortir avec leurs amis
nous aurions aimé les rencontrer mais on
nous a refusé l'accès
il y a trois éléments clés pour une
organisation comme l'opus dei
le pouvoir l'argent et le contrôle comme
sans contrôle on n'a rien
croit que le pouvoir vient précisément
de ce contrôle le contrôle des esprits
[Musique]
le plus d y est surtout de l' influence
en espagne aux philippines au mexique et
dans certains pays d'amérique du sud
dans ces pays des membres dirige des
écoles des universités des hôpitaux et
occupent des postes importants
il tente de répandre leurs idées contre
l'avortement le mariage gay l'aide
médicale à mourir
évidemment ils occupent des postes
influents où il possède des entreprises
importantes il ne fait aucun doute ils
ont du pouvoir partout dans le monde est
ce qu'on doit craindre cette situation
je ne sais pas
vous président de l'équateur est un
membre de l'opus dei est candidat à la
présidence au chili lé aussi
qu est ce qu on doit craindre au canada
pas grand chose quand on entre en
contact avec l'organisation au canada on
sent bien qu'elle a besoin de recruter
plus de membres qui ont du pouvoir et de
l'argent
le nom opus dei ne figure pas sur la
majorité des portes d'entrée l'oeuvre ne
posséderaient pas d'immeuble au canada
ni dans aucun pays les centres sont la
propriété de fondation dirigée par des
membres de l'opus
[Musique]
le secret entourant le plus délirant
forcerait pour certains l'idée d'une
société occulte qui chercheraient à
s'infiltrer dans la société
cette image a d'une organisation secrète
tu as le pouvoir et qui nous manipulent
sans qu'on s'en rende compte ça c'est la
théorie du complot c'est pour le
sociologue des religions alain bouchard
le plus d in et fluence pas la société
canadienne sait déjà qui s'investissent
dans leur travail qui sont convaincus
qu'ils peuvent transformer le monde et
ça c'est une façon de transformer le
mans tout comme aussi des écologistes
font la même chose et c'est donc de ce
point de vue là oui sauf que qui ont
levure parlement à ottawa lorsqu'un
député commence à questionner des
questions comme l'avortement même son
parti va laisser de côté donc son parle
d' influencer ce qu'ils sont capables de
transformer des choses pour le moment
semble avoir beaucoup de difficulté à
effet je crois que ça va tout simplement
s'éteindre
il ya tellement de choses qui sont
totalement archaïque ne va pas durer
pourtant canada les rangs de l'opus dei
ont grossi de 300 nouveaux membres au
cours des 15 dernières années selon
l'organisation
lui les gains se sont fait
principalement en alberta où leur nombre
a triplé et ils sont deux fois plus
nombreux en colombie britannique
et le ratio à la résidence with the view
on poursuit les activités envers et
contre tout
évidemment comme n'importe quelle
organisation
on a à faire
pour poursuivre sa mission l'opus dei a
besoin d'argent il compte sur les
salaires des numéraires et les dons des
membres surnuméraires le plus reçoit
aussi des legs de ceux qui les appuient
d'où l'importance de recruter et de
garder ses membres
genou
difficile de connaître la richesse de la
multinationale qui est l'opus dei mais
la ferveur de ses membres ne fait aucun
doute
[Musique]
pour vous et que je suis sype mais
j'espère de temps vers la sainteté c'est
un peu fou humainement parlant c'est un
peu fou où je vous l'accord
vous avez parlé de code difficile d'où
sort mais l'immense majorité c'est des
gens heureux qui ont trouvé le bonheur
dans l'esprit de l'évangile
[Musique]
catherine tissier s'est mariée elle
travaille comme préposée dans un hôpital
et tente d'oublier cette vie qu'on lui a
imposée se rendent compte qu'on était
manipulé et ça c'est si difficile à
accepter a accepté
[Musique]
moi j'étais pas fait pour ça sauf qu'on
m'a fait croire pendant des années
j'étais fait pour ça
carlos miguel a quitté l'opus dei avec
25 $ dans ses poches il a repris sa vie
en main à 51 ans quand on lui demande ce
qu'il apprécie le plus de sa nouvelle
vie il répond que la liberté
tard
je n'avais jamais réalisé que je n'étais
pas libre j'étais un esclave
littéralement pendant près de 40 ans
visitez quoi être un esclave
je ne dirai j'étais mûr non j'étais pas
mûres 19 ans on est encore jeune on
connaît pas la vie
c'est très jeune pour prendre une
décision comme ça là
[Musique]
vincent du rocher est devenu papa il
enseigne encore à temps partiel
c'est vrai que moi j'ai dit oui mais si
j'avais su à quoi je m'engageais je
pourrai jamais dit oui comprenez vous
[Musique]
e